A town had a population
of 11,256 in 1995.
By 2010, the population
in that town had
increased by 4,312.
Estimate the town's population
in 2010 by first rounding
these two numbers to the
nearest hundred.
So we could figure out the
exact population just by
adding these two, but they
want us to round to the
nearest hundred first and get an
estimate, and then add, so
it'll be an estimate of
the town's population.
So first we have this 11,256.
That's the population in 1995.
11,256.
We need to round to the nearest
hundred, so let's look
at the hundreds place here.
So this is either going to go
down to 200 or go up to 300,
depending on what the
next place is or
the next lowest place.
So we go down to the tens
place, we see a 5.
5 is 5 or greater, so we want
to round this number up.
We are going to round up.
So if you round up
to the nearest
hundred, you get 11,000.
Instead of having 256, we're
rounding up to 300.
300 is closer to 256
than 200 is.
That's why we're rounding
up to that.
That's why it's to the
nearest hundred.
Now, we added 4,312
people, so 4,312.
Now once again, we look
at the hundreds place.
We go one spot below that.
The question we're trying to
answer: Do we go down to 4,300
or do we go up to 4,400?
Which one is closer?
Well, we see we only
have a 1 here.
1 is definitely less than 5,
so we want to round down.
So 312 is closer to 300.
We round down to just a 3 here
and these get zeroed out.
So 4,300.
And now we're ready to add
our rounded numbers.
0 plus 0 is 0.
3 plus 3 is 6.
Let's put a comma here
so it's easy to
read every third digit.
1 plus 4 is 5, and then 1 plus--
we have nothing here,
so we just bring down that 1.
We could have written
that addition there.
We're adding those
two numbers.
So our estimate of the town's
population in 2010 is 15,600.